votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
[Musique]
les dents
m
avant je
le
jc féroce
[Musique]
aujourd'hui bien
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
chez une petite surprise pour nous parce
que je vous ai offert des chaussures
voilà je vous ai offert des baskets bien
fait longtemps que je devais lui offrait
des baskets et j'ai une autre mais
pourquoi mais non mais c'est bon on va
pas dire pourquoi maintenant qu'on sait
pas pourquoi
une raison à ça ce canon mais c'est bon
voilà c'est votre cadeau voilà je vous
ai racheté les baskets voilà abîmer les
autres anciennes est passé à la nuit
alors voilà c'est parce que il fait pas
de cadeau pour rien le mec vous le savez
tous ce truc là c'est un beau cadeau à
celle de la jordan c'est une très belle
paire merci beaucoup mais c'est pour se
faire pardonner d'une d'une usine est
d'une bêtise d'une bombe assez bon
troisième république tu croyais frère tu
crois que tu allais faire un concert de
violoncelle ou quoi
c'est quoi cette tenue là non mais sans
dec costume présidentiel c'est votre
coach brésilien mais dégueulasse ça
s'est passé que françois hollande y
papier comme ça il n'est plus président
en personne habillée comme ça vous êtes
dégueulasse c'est comme association des
cônes estime la poubelle c'est quoi
c'est à dire un costume on dirait que
j'allais faire le tyrolien la non mais
sans déconner c'est une catastrophe
mais on raconte on raconte henri tincq
la chaussure non alors oui on raconte
alors est ce qu'il ya des fois il ya des
choses qui vous sont arrivés à vous dans
l'équipe et les des gens disent c'est
vrai qu'il fait s'annonce comme très
grave s'il fait ça mais en fait il fait
50 items beaucoup et alors cet été je
trouvais plus mes baskets et je vois lui
et bentalha qui se marre qu'ils se
marchent ne prend pas et j'y vais
doucement ce que je me dis me prépare un
coup et quand j'arrive je retrouve mes
baskets dans lequel cyril a fait ses
besoins
cet ancien des choses que c'était un
chien qui est passé excusez moi mais est
ce que c'est le chien qui m'a envoyé la
photo de la basket de france n'ont pas
te fais chier ça drôle
je trouvais ça drôle que je tiens face
la voilà mr toilettes vous visez bien je
n'avais pas aux toilettes
non mais alors tu vous dire la vérité on
a passé l'été avec lui il était tout le
temps au téléphone à la fin avec malik
bentalha on en avait marre on a dit ben
voilà on va lui donner de leçon allez
faites vous avez longtemps c'est pas
nous c'est eux
suivez-moi pas compliqué
[Applaudissements]
et on le voit en photo avec l'excellent
vincent cassel donc là voilà et c'est à
cette période que tu rencontres une
personne qui va beaucoup compter pour
toi franck qui va énormément aidé pour
tes réalisations tu va le former sur
plein de disciplines
à cette époque il ya ton documentaire
good dot c'est ça est ce que je me
trompe pour l'instant non non non tout
est vrai et bien cet ami devenu très
très proches
au fil du temps va également céder sur
génération molosses est ce que tu vois
de qui je veux parler génération
molosses ces noms du boys band
regardez voila voila c'est une trappe à
deux générations boli venons en aux
faits avec tous ces indices est ce que
tu penses à une personne en particulier
si je te dis ludovic est ce que ça
t'évoque quelque chose c'est peu c'est
vrai tu partagé beaucoup de choses avec
lui il est mort de rire
regarde
ludovic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors avec un taux qui n'avait pas vu
non je te suis pas sur sa caisse non je
ne suis pas ses organes on avait une
photo de vacances de vous un homme est
arrêté
non mais sans déconner non mais tu
connais ludovic non bien sûr que non
ludovic si et quand par exemple bas en
2003 quand j'ai quand j'étais avec toi
sur le sur l'euro prévenait dormir à la
maison à la rue de la roquette sur mon
clic clac
non non tout est faux pour pas rentrer à
moulins où est ce que vous connaissez
cette personne n'a envie sûr que non
quoi vous ne connaissez pas du tout été
longue et ses annexes c'est quoi oui
madame est servie en appel non mais sans
déconner quoi leur froc vraiment aucun
rapport non vraiment non alors il est
venu me dire pendant la pub montre avec
galère le bon mec épreuve
[Rires]
waouh
[Applaudissements]
cephalon
alors on a voulu piéger franck
gastambide et lui permet avec génie tu
joue le jeu et n'a pas du tout joué les
journaux ça rigole était un chien